all right so we had a little bit of rain
and uh kind of was just only the west
side had some sprinkles south mainly
north did get some sprinkles north part
of the valley south mainly some showers
yeah but i was just so happy because
last week this was the day that i had
friends because eight day forecast is
pretty far out really far out and i was
really putting my money down what do you
do do you do like a tiger woods fist
pump when that happens i go out okay i
go do cup cart wheels
my neighbors call the cops you're not
that flexible i'm trying to pick no i'm
not believe me i am not honest can you
actually do a cartwheel no okay in my
head and sleep yes
but physically no because i want to come
back to work the next day i want to
i don't want to call him sick for the
rest of the week because i pulled
something all right live look outside
another live look at the strip we got
some great sunset shots if you got one
send it to us we want to show it on tv
all right 78 our high for the day today
so we did not even reach 80. 68
overnight for the low not bad 86 is
where we should be so below average
we're gonna be below average again
tomorrow the record territory for this
time now is 99 degrees that was set back
in 1980. we are done with the triple
digits officially all right the last
little record for the latest triple
digits was on october 4th 74 in
summerlin right now 76 for aliante 79
centennial hills same for downtown at 79
78 sunrise manor 79 for green valley
roads ranch double sevens for you seven
hills included silverando ranch at 78 76
southern highlands and 76 for henderson
that's a lot of neighborhoods outside of
town 79 for pro 70 even for boulder city
82 for laughlin and again 94 for death
valley didn't even reach 100 degrees
there today there are still storms out
there but unfortunately it's been great
year for arizona and we continue to
still see some of those storms there
right around just north of phoenix just
south of sedona and flagstaff but here
though now we're dry after those storms
look at that those storms we had mainly
favoring the west side and southwest
part of the valley with sprinkles
elsewhere and look at the storms we had
east of us that were really having
potential and then died out before they
reached the moapa valley and mesquite
now the rain chance this is why you need
to watch eight news now consistently
with me and my team because this changed
on us we had some good chances for
friday latest now guidance shows that we
only have a seven percent chance so
friday doesn't look too good as far as
rainfall chances go wind forecast does
show also winds should stay light for
tomorrow to pick up again we think on
thursday and friday overnight 65
decreasing storms and then clearing
overnight
83 tomorrow mostly sunny and drier and
comfortable tomorrow like 83
neighborhood by neighborhood
temperatures in those low to mid 80s
across the valley 79 for summerlin and
anthem here's your eight day forecast
now guys cooling off that slight chance
on friday and then temperatures drop
into those
80s for the weekend and then look at
the wind on monday and tuesday with
temperatures dropping to 68 degrees can
you believe it wow hey guys just want to
let you know that i was assigned earlier
today to the g2e conference okay so i
had to interview
vanna white guys
so i asked her two things all right one
what makes you and your family come to
las vegas all the time and two give me a
nugget a secret that nobody knows about
you
on the set here's what she had to say
i love vegas i love
the gambling part i love the incredible
restaurants
the the shows
you know when you come here you just
have a good time it's like being in
adult disneyland it really is and every
time i come here
when i leave i feel fulfilled i feel
happy it's like a great escape
i have snacks behind the puzzle board
nobody knows that right yeah they always
put like nice little things back there
like cookies and donuts and peanuts and
so that's something that nobody really
that's behind the actual screens that
you touch yeah it is is there a is there
a favorite of yours like chips ahoy or
something
no it's always different i never know i
have to say it must be the donuts though
i think it's the donuts that i like
because i don't get donuts at home
guys look at that
she has snacks behind her touch board
which is crazy because i do too
there we go
i'm just like vanna
that crazy though something that we did
not know about wheel of fortune which
airs tonight
back over to you guys
well done thanks ted